do you think it would have helped if the
president were more involved in the
policy itself oh he was deeply involved
that's the thing that I was so pleased
and impressed with he really rolled up
his sleeves so actually he's up to speed
on the issue he knows he knows the
circumstances what I worry about Nora is
that if we don't do this then he'll just
go work with Democrats to try and change
Obamacare and that's not gonna that's
hardly a conservative thing this is a
can-do president it was a business guy
who wants to get things done and I know
that he wants to get things done with
the Republican Congress but if this
Republican Congress allows the perfect
to be the enemy of the good I worry
we'll push the president into into
working with Democrats he's been
suggesting that as much I mean have you
reached out to the Democrats yet to work
on this bill Pelosi no I'm trying to get
this bill passed I don't Nancy and I see
things very very differently I don't
want that you guys hang out in the same
page the prezi United States saying he's
going to work with Democrats on this
yeah I knew he was saying that I don't
want that Deb Anita why I want a
patient-centered system i don't want
government running healthcare the
government shouldn't tell you what you
must do with your life with your
healthcare we should give people choices